- We talked with Kelly Rowland
a few months ago, actually,
and she said that you
were in the room on Zoom
for the birth of her son, which is crazy.
I mean, it's super special,
but also, like, what?
Like, you saw all that?
(Michelle laughs)
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah.
- You! (laughs)
That is.
♪ Friendship ♪
(laughs) That is.
- Listen,
if I ever doubted my place
in Kelly Rowland's life,
getting the invitation
to watch her giving birth
put all doubt out the window.
- Oh my gosh, that, it would scar me.
Like, I'm glad I never saw
that before I got pregnant.
I would've never probably-
- It was beautiful, Kelly!
It was beautiful.
- You know what?
Michelle, I'm so different.
I'm so different. (laughs)